The incomparable Jackie Chan has been thrilling
audiences for over four decades with his singular
combination of insane martial arts skills
and great comedic timing.
The other quality that sets Chan apart from
his peers is that he does his own stunts,
no matter how dangerous, cheating death virtually
every time he makes a movie.
Here are a few scenes that posed grave danger
to the life and limbs of one of the greatest
action stars of all time.
Drunken Master
Snake in the Eagle's Shadow was one of Chan's
first lead roles back in 1978, introducing
his distinct comic touch and distinguishing
him from the great Bruce Lee.
The movie also featured rising star Hwang
Jang-Lee, the "king of the leg fighters,"
whose powerful kicks have become legend.
Jang-Lee and Chan's onscreen chemistry was
so good that Jang-Lee was cast as the villain
in Chan's follow-up, Drunken Master.
While shooting Snake, Jang-Lee had accidentally
kicked out one of Chan's teeth, but Chan had
apparently failed to learn his lesson.
He suffered one of his first major on-set
injuries when one of Lee's thundering kicks
connected with his brow bone, breaking it
and nearly causing him to lose an eye.
In a 2014 interview, Hwang Jang-Lee was asked
to rank his top five kung-fu fighters — and
he didn't hesitate to rank Jackie Chan #1.
Project A
In 1983's Project A, Hong Kong police team
up with the Coast Guard to fight pirates at
the turn of the 20th century, and it's pure
slapstick comedy by way of blinding martial
arts and insane stunt work.
One of the most dangerous things Chan ever
did appears in the finished movie, and it
may have been the first scene to give audiences
the notion that Chan may be superhuman.
In the scene, Chan's character Ma dangles
from the face of a 60-foot clock tower — but
things don't go well.
After losing his grip and falling six stories
through a couple of awnings, Chan lands directly
on his head.
Chan injured his spine during the stunt, but
the camera doesn't cut away.
Instead, extras drag him to his feet, and
he continues the scene.
Police Story
The Police Story series has been particularly
hazardous to Chan, starting with the 1985
original.
At the climax of a prolonged brawl inside
a shopping mall, Chan jumps from a railing
onto a pole covered in Christmas lights.
The glass was fake, so Chan at least wasn't
sliced to ribbons.
But the lights had heated up the pole, causing
him to sustain serious burns on his hands.
The hard landing also dislocated Chan's pelvis
and injured two vertebrae.
At least the stunt looked great in the finished
film, because there was no way they were getting
a second take.
Armour of God
It was a completely routine shot that resulted
in Chan's closest brush with mortality.
While shooting the 1986 film Armour of God
in Yugoslavia, Chan had to jump from the wall
of a castle to a nearby tree branch, a maneuver
that he'd normally be able to pull off in
his sleep.
Instead, he came crashing down onto the rocks
below, cracking his skull and sending a piece
of it into his brain, resulting in doctors
having to put a metal plate in his head.
It seems like the kind of thing that might
put an action star out of commission for good,
but the near-fatal injury simply became the
highlight of Armour of God's outtake reel
— and over the next two decades, Chan would
continue to risk it all for the enjoyment
of his millions of fans.
Armour of God II: Operation Condor
The second film in the Armour of God series,
released in 1991, sees Chan in Indiana Jones
mode, chasing after hidden treasure and dealing
with secret cults and hidden Nazi bases.
It's packed to the brim with crazy fight sequences
and stunts, but it was another reasonably
simple task that nearly took Chan out.
Clever editing hides Chan's terrible tumble
during filming.
In the extended scene, Chan actually loses
his grip on the chain and plummets to the
ground.
Even though he had dislocated his sternum,
he gives a thumbs up.
It could have been worse — if he had landed
differently, he might have finished the job
he started on Project A and dislocated his
head.
Police Story 3: Supercop
It's safe to say that most leading men have
never had their face rearranged by a helicopter,
but Jackie Chan is not most leading men.
An incredibly perilous sequence in 1992's
Police Story 3: Supercop has Chan leap onto
a rope ladder dangling from a chopper, while
the pilot attempts to shake him off.
That wasn't even the dangerous part.
When the helicopter later lands on a moving
train, all Chan has to do it avoid it as he
dangles from a rotating railway apparatus.
A miss revealed in the outtakes resulted in
a fractured rib, broken shoulder, and dislocated
cheekbone.
Chan had to hang on with his good shoulder
while half-conscious, waiting for the crew
to cut him down.
It's easy to see how much worse it could have
been.
The Legend of Drunken Master
It took 16 years for Drunken Master to receive
a sequel, 1994's The Legend of Drunken Master.
Its climactic fight sequence is legendary,
but it was almost very different.
Chan disagreed with the director's vision
for the final scene, and the conflict led
to him quitting the uncompleted production.
Chan himself took over directing duties…
and decided to repeatedly risk lighting himself
on fire.
What makes the sequence even more amazing
is that the take in the finished film is the
second one.
Chan felt that the first take didn't have
the proper rhythm, so he shot it again, because
he's apparently invincible.
Who Am I?
1998's Who Am I?
places Chan in the middle of international
intrigue, working with a CIA agent to solve
a mystery surrounding missing scientists while
dodging hitmen in scenic locales — and of
course, performing one of the most insane
stunts ever put to film.
Rotterdam, in the Netherlands, is home to
Willemswerf, one of the world's more unique
skyscrapers.
It features a sloping glass facade that runs
down one entire side of the 24-story building.
In the climactic scene of the film, Chan slides
down the entire length of the facade.
Chan accomplished this stunt by literally
just sliding down the entire length of the
facade, unassisted, with no harnesses or other
special equipment, exactly as seen in the
film.
The slide takes nearly 45 seconds to complete
before Chan comes to a bone-jarring halt,
catching himself from flying over the edge.
It took him two weeks to work up the courage
to attempt what may be the most dangerous
stunt ever put to film.
New Police Story
Since the old Police Story series obviously
wanted him dead, Chan could have been forgiven
if he'd wanted to skip the 2004 reboot New
Police Story.
But in characteristic fashion, he threw himself
into the film's kinetic action scenes with
gusto.
In one particularly terrifying scene, Chan
pursues a gang member who distracts him from
the chase by gunning down the driver of a
loaded double-decker bus.
Chan leaps onto the roof of the out-of-control
bus, which proceeds to cause massive property
damage while the hazards come at him fast
and furious.
It's easy to spot about a hundred things that
could have gone wrong during the filming of
this sequence, any one of which could have
resulted in Chan literally losing his head.
But if it weren't crazy dangerous to shoot,
it wouldn't really be a Jackie Chan movie.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!